hi my name is mention him I'm a
visualization developer warframe
my talk is about automatic labeling in
version 12 thank you my name is Minh I'm
a developer in warframe for the
visualization so today I'm going to talk
about automated labeling in
visualization this is probably part 4
and so I so I will mostly it's kind of
like a review for what we have done
before version 12 so I will talk about
what kind of automations we have and I
also talk about what kind of the you
know the factors the the automation is
considering I'll give some examples and
but the main idea is to just just to
show you that how labeling can be very
useful just in the visualization itself
so I hope that I mean I have seen that
many presenters have used label stuff in
their talk which is great and this is
just a simple example here that you know
you don't really need to show the code
to for the for the people to see that
this is a normal distribution you could
just add a very simple label there and
avoid all these code there and it is it
is like very frequently seen that in the
literature's that people just put some
graph just to try to say something but
the graph sometimes itself doesn't
explain much and people usually put a
lot of text under it and I mean I don't
know you guys but usually when I'm
scanning through papers I would look at
the visualizations and try to see that
if there is something I'm interested in
and in this presentation I'm going to
use a lot of a lot of flip View so I
don't know if you are familiar with that
it's just
instead of manipulate it is which is you
know doing things on the fly I'm
generating a lot of pictures
in advance so I don't run into the risk
here but the way I can do this has just
click on graphics and it will cycle
through what I have already generated
for example I please so just for the
holiday and I have like two other scenes
listed here first ones the twitch talk
it's talking about the same objet the
talk is about what's new in 12 which is
the second link so I encourage you if
you have not seen the what's new in 12
they are pretty pictures near right so
like come back to what I just said about
the graph in the literature's this is
very common type of charts that you can
see so people put the labels on the axes
and then rotate the labels 90 degree I
think that there's a disadvantage of
this is that you know the real state on
paper is very valuable and you are going
to have like a lot of it's going to
squeeze in so say that you know the
spaces is the same but because you have
to show everything in then you that
vertical labels layer is going to be
expensive so I think that you know it's
a better idea is that you can put it
inside but then it is because it's
colored if it is not colored if which is
in grayscale in a lot of paper then you
run into the problem of that it's
obscured so the automation here is that
we come up some idea that we can
actually set the labels that in the way
that you can alternate and it's still
compact and I would just want to show
you that it is not how coded lights
alternating between each so it's
actually you know it depends on the size
of the label is going to do the packing
automatically
so another example here is that right so
there are many groups so this is the six
countries they are energy production
chart and then for the each country
there are five categories so if you the
same scene if you have put in the name
of the countries on the axis they
certainly will work but it may take a
lot of space and then it's not it
doesn't give you the other flexibilities
if you want to add more labels so here
this is just another example how the
automations can be used and the code
here so basically it's just like using
call-out wrapper on the data twice there
are those two rappers are for this
individual call-out and the other one
that's the group labels is using chart
labels right so I am dividing the labels
automations in two sections the first
one is the data visualization the second
one is the function visualization in the
data visualization is what we have done
for the tools in the labeling include
the label the redder so it's a rapper so
it's you know you can wrap around the
data point and space about the label and
then some options if you like
so the first ones this is just a list
plot the second one is the Geo list plot
I'm just taking some II am the examples
here so they are many functions are
supported the second tool is call-out
it's very similar to lay down to two
labeled the only difference is there is
a extra leader line there just for some
extra graphic clarification the same
scene the first one is this plot and
second one is the pie chart
we have two options I mean we have
options one is plot labels
the other one is chart labels plot
labels is a plain is applied to the list
plots well anyone that does it ended
with chart and the chart labels is the
one using the charts so the syntax is
very similar but they are using the
labels and in respect to the structure
of the data for example that the first
one is the least line plot I have three
data sets so the syntax will be just
plot labels go to label one two three
and so it's an end for the bar chart
it's going to be you know the previous
one the one we saw about the energy
production that has two dimensions the
first one is the group and the second
one is the the categories of the energy
so that kind of sense is translated to
the chart lab our structure so this is
all well documented I'll just kind of
like recap the functionality for the
data visualizations they also have
another option called the labeling
function it is a very powerful option
because we just provide everything to
you and you can do whatever you want so
it includes the values of the each
element and tell you it tells you the
index of which current of which one
which item we are currently at and the
third one is labels coming from all the
rappers and previous aid options so you
can use them to generate your customized
labels here I'm not using something
fancy I'm just giving an example for the
for you for using labeling function so
the third one is a bubble chart and I
want to mention that why do we have this
problem is so weird
it's not just the those options we have
like geo labels event labels and counter
labels they are already existed you know
from various of time since barriers of
time and they are kind of spatial labels
for each spatial visualization and we
have a lot of visualization functions so
each of them might have a little bit you
know a difference from each other and
these are all supported functions
currently we have for the previous set
options and wrapper so it's quite a lot
we started from this plot and we
graduate we gradually extended it to
other functions it's not still not
comprehensive though so we are working
on that now we're talking about labels
in the function visualization so it's a
very similar idea with we also have
labeled but since it is not data point
so the label here is actually written
around the function itself and you say a
label if you don't specify any position
is going to put on the end of the of the
curves but if you do specify a location
the well it sounds like it's not so
different from just using text but the
scene is laughs when you are using text
you have to specify precise coordinates
that you want to put the label here it
is not you just need to specify say the
first one is a plot you just specify the
X location and it will automatically
figure out the Y location and kind of
like move the labels so that it doesn't
cross over the curve so that's the
alternation we are talking about and
that is relatively easy and here we had
a parametric plot which is it's much
more complicated because it's just
difficult to figure out that you know
where the curve is going but in the end
we we still find it a way to make it
work I mean
I'm sure that you can find some cases
it's going to run into the curve just
because that it is sometimes the curve
you know can like come back and make a
loop and make a knot so that is
difficult but so that is why we have the
call-out which allows you to have a
leader line to pinpoint to the features
you want to label on the curve the
second example here is a region plot so
that is something new added and the
third one is a plat 3d so you can see
that you can add some labels layer and
then just point out some features we
also have plat labels so very similar to
the previous case this is for each data
I mean each function so the first
example is a plot and you can I think
you can see there yes so at least two
labels if there is no any algorithm
running it will run into each other
because they are very close so these the
automation there is just trying to find
an optimal optimize the position so they
don't run into each other the second
case is a parametric plot the automation
is that how do you find a place that
point to the curve well this is an easy
case because none of the curves are
overlapping
but when layer overlapping you don't
want to find a position that is too
ambiguous so that is kind of hole in
algorithm as dealing with and currently
the supported functions are here the
same we are trying to expand it to other
functions it would be gradually and the
functions that we have worked on for the
function visualization in data
visualizations they are kind of the core
functions we have a lot of the newer
functions that are built upon them so so
we are expecting you know to do more and
in an easier way so I want to point out
that there are few functions are spatial
the first one is the
discrete plot and discrete plus 3b so
although they are function
visualizations while they do not
generate curve they generate points
because it's discrete plot so the
behavior is slightly different so so I
just want to point out so for example
that if it is a plot this prime P is
going to be u it's going to generate a
label in the end of the plot but instead
because the T the variable is presented
here is going to generate point labels
so for example if I hope I use hot form
on the label so it doesn't generate the
point like that I just want to point out
this is something special
and another thing special is feature
space plot and future space plus 3d I
would also use this example to introduce
that the two options that we also
implemented for version tie off which
I'm gonna just show in it will be shown
in a second
I'm going to use the data from the
example data about Titanic survivors or
that the information so we can look at
the information of this the first class
person and this is the age and the
gender and survived or died so the data
points is about 1300 the length of it
so we can use machine learning stuff the
dimension reduce to reduce dimensions
into two the results of air doesn't have
any meaningful units it's just a you
know like X Y values and then we can
visualize this using this plot and you
can see that the labeling function is
just printing out the data and you can
see that you know this plot I mean the
dimension reduce successfully
kind of categorize them in a way and the
label here is just the purpose of label
here the automation is so that they are
not running into the points and trying
to remove the labels that running into
each other right so if I set the label
visibility which is an option in the
cutout we can see that this is before
the labels get removed they still runs
through the algorithm so you can see
that most of the labels are not running
into the points but they can run into
each other and that is not desired still
because the information is blocked and
the other sinner you can see that we
actually added some screen behind the
labels so when they are stacking to each
other they are not just completely
unreadable so that is and lastly that is
the option that you know a lot of people
are asking that what if I just I'm fine
with lolly overlapping I just want to
show them all that is the option and we
can just use feature space plot on the
data itself and to see that the features
house feature space plot is doing its
magic to categorize the data and I think
it's pretty neat graph and what all the
ones were mostly that have the complete
information they somehow get transformed
into some continuous line I don't know
but for the for the informations that
tooltip should show up so for the
informations that is not completed they
kind of get clustered there I Ivan no
idea why he's doing that but just one
pointed out
the other option is called label in size
this option is especially useful if your
label is not text for example it can be
images so I saw that it will be fun so I
get some zombie images and I can plot it
with this plot and the tooltip itself is
there's a nice big image according to
the size of the image of your input but
you can see that the the labeled image
actually is chunk and the same thing
that the algorithm is trying to avoid
running into other points and trying to
avoid 1 into e into each other but you
but you can still see that these two
cases are running into each other the
reason is that we saw that you know as
long as it is overlaid in just a little
bit we can still see the contacts so we
don't need to be so aggressive around
removing everything so so that is the
reason but you can see that the point
over here that is just there's no way it
can be placed in a way that it doesn't
run into other images completely or
running into other points so that that
was removed and put it into a tube so I
saw that I could get another set of
images which is called Asian zombie I
don't know and then see that how feature
space plot catalysed name and apparently
is kind of like degree of decomposition
so right so just the same thing here so
the label in size is and top-level the
first-tier option in the visualization
function
right so here is a bunch of labeling
automation I want to show you these so
this is the flip view so while I'm
adding more points you can see the label
moved because it was going to hit the
point so that's you can see the label
although automatic labeling algorithm
working there another factor that we
considered is the density of the points
so so this is just a few points so every
one is labeled but when there are more
points you can see labels are removed so
it just this is the density of the
points another one is the image size to
image size aspect ratio and pleura inge
it's all going to affect the real estate
of the plot and that is the men's in
that's deciding the algorithm so so we
can just see that when the image size is
increased you see more labels and for
the list point plus 3d we have the view
point taken into considerations so it is
3d point if you look carefully none of
the labels is blocking the points ok
other automations for the rim plot its
add in some extra informations about the
re and the real part and imaginary part
on the labels and you only need to
specify expressions and it will pick up
the function itself the label location
for the curve I did not do anything
special to move this label it will find
the curve itself and move it along so it
doesn't run into the curve and it
doesn't go out of the plow range so all
this is you know it's just call out
in the in the label and this is just the
location of the leader so I did not
specify where my label should be in the
detail and this is just another example
how the Optima optimization problem
solving is he used in figuring out the
label here the same thing for the pie
chart there are so many cases that the
user is asking that how do we how do I
avoid the label being collided when the
the pies are very small so here's the
solution we've we have for you right
they are largest léa léa a lot of other
special plots that we have to a craft
for the automation one is the parametric
plot which I mentioned how to find the
positions so they are not too crowded
and the region plaid or the color is
completely different the one that if you
put the label outside the region then it
will have a leader if you put the label
inside of the region then it doesn't
have the leader so that's a cue so the
3d plus and parametric plus 3d and the
counter plot which you can use the
labeling to label the poles and zeros
right I love them so I'm running out of
time but this is an example from what's
new in 12 on the website it is using the
labeling stuff in some region stuff to
label the Venn diagram I saw this pretty
neat and I don't know if you I mean this
one is pretty well known but I don't
know have you ever thought about how to
put the Venn diagram four or four parts
so yeah the code is not very long so if
you have some time and interested so
please read through so that concludes my
talk thank you
you